Joe Biden promised that if elected he'll
cure cancer yeah which explains why just
this morning President Trump came out in
support of cancer yeah Wow
he did he said there's a you know
there's good cancer he's bad cancer
right good cells on both side cells on
both sides let's not demonize he's sick
of the media demonizing cancer
a new poll just came out about the 2020
election and it shows Joe Biden easily
defeating President Trump easily
that's what the test yeah yeah true win
all Biden needs to do between now and
next November is stop talking that's the
only thing it could screw it up you know
I told that like a joke it's kind of not
a joke
it would help and what that would help
would help if he just went fishing for
like here just smile a lot and show up
exactly Starbucks CEO Howard Schultz
said he might still run for president
yeah yeah when asked why he's
considering joining a race with 27 other
candidates the CEO of Starbucks said I
love long lines
me a lot of money it's burned okay
enough about Starbucks